yes this is a dream come true um and she
wrote and directed and stars in a
personal new project life and beth a
show about revisiting your past to
understand your present and there's a
very special actress in life and bath
who plays the younger version of you i'm
going to show a clip so we can introduce
her
[Music]
you want to try some
okay okay all right come here open your
mouth like this
ah
get a little more good job
okay a little more
okay
now look
don't i just fix it
[Music]
oh that's so well shot oh god that
moment's so poetic and beautiful
oh it's so haunting i'm just like set
okay she's here please welcome violet
young
hi violet
hey you guys thanks so much for having
us violet may i ask like what was amy's
approach like what advice did she give
you about playing her younger self
yeah i mean i think i just tried to
learn as much about young beth from from
amy and i got so much wonderful guidance
um
you know obviously dynamics with family
and friends and just kind of growing up
as a as a teenager in you know middle
school to high school yeah i got some
really great advice so i'm excited for
everyone to see to see young beth and
amy when you met violet what was it that
you identified in her
there was you know no offense to anyone
else who auditioned but there was just
no
no one else she just came it was it was
like you know if you watch american idol
or something and people come in and then
somebody opens their mouth and you're
just like
okay we have a star you know it was like
it was totally like that okay as a last
question violet why should everybody
watch life and
bath i think everyone should watch life
in beth because i think you'll laugh and
you'll cry
and your mascara will drip all over your
face um in the best way so i think it's
it's a really beautiful stew it's a it's
a bit of everything and i'm excited for
everyone to see it i absolutely love
that
amy and violet life and bath is
available on hulu now i celebrate you
both i celebrate the show and um thank
you both so much for being here
[Music]